拍短日平需要天赋吗 需要
但不需要你的天赋
咱用别人的天赋不好吧
给大家介绍一个方法
咱们弄吧
就可以让你拍摄短日平的速度快十倍
而且概率会更高
方法也很简单
就是把你说什么
和怎么说分开
大家可能看过巧克斯的演讲
或者郡老师的演讲
对吧
你看那个批评一多好看啊
但是谁上的话呢
这俩是分开的
你我演讲的时候需要有PT吗
我说什么是我来决定的
但是那个PT在样是
还要好看吗
你抱看不得吵楼啊
都丢人啊
但是你不会认为那个PT
是他自己做的吧
对吧
所以关注点
在这儿
在送哪有支持吧
你看我们那个视频拍的
多随意
也买一送一
今天直播的时候
装有了过一个问我
说郡老师的这个流量也特别好
但是没有做关注为什么
主要这个值得点挺重要的
流量这个东西啊
他去决于平台
这个关注呢
去决于你的家事
就平台是怎么看呢
哎
我不知道这个说得多不每次说的这儿
说他就会不怕
啊
买你们自己体会吧
就说这个互动数据
什么点赞呢
什么评论呢
什么收场呢
这个东西就定的
你的流量
哈哈哈
你能理一下吧
但是有没有价值
关注这是去决于关注
好可以很重要
我在问一边啊
那这个你要好好思考的
你不要认为你懂了
流量去决于
好
关注去决于
如果你能明白这个道理的话
我们就开始在思考一下
其实你会发现
像条不说演讲啊
像李运演讲啊
他只需要关注内容就可以了
他不需要关注
行事那个行事有不收变
因为那个东西
就那个样子就一样好看了
他只要关注内容就好了
对不对
那么刚才我们说了
这个流量去就于什么
啊
那个他是有一定的概率的
但是是
他可不是随机数
他是他是有一定的
算法的
你符合这个算法才可以
那么我们要不要一个一个的事呢
就是我们很多人在做内容的时候
为什么你浪费很多时间呀
你需要关内容怎么行呀
你还你最后关注于缩什么
你还要关注于怎么说
但是一下呢
各位其实有些时候
你可以
你想工程
就看
看人家怎么做的时候
不是所有的人都看
你只看他是怎么说的
不用看他说什么
先看他是怎么说的
这个是可以推算出来的
他该推算出来
因为他是你成功的吗
你怎么说
我当然怎么说的
我发现很多人超得不会超的
没毛糊的一把转
你只需要知道他是怎么说的
然后就想让你只需要知道
那个PB的那个魔法
以后用这个魔法就可以
那种还是你的
九里子啊
比如说金龙老师的小叔
你们看不吗
金龙老师的小叔
其实是一个结果
一个逃了
就是谁也谁
然后遇到一个什么问题
拔掉山中里的
然后遇到个其余
结果那个局势务工
然后就必了
你看是不是
张务劲
驱逐
对吧
然后
断育
对吧
然后立库充
你看他是不是都是这样的
他其实就是里边的故事
不一样的
但是这个结构
其实是一样的
所以呢
你可以把你的
说什么和怎么说分开
你只需要找到那么两个
就可以
具体怎么做啊
我给你给你个具体操作
第一个什么
第一个
就是
印象工程
在你这个领域里边
符合你的这种情况
找到两个
已经跑出来的结果
跑出来的
别只一个两个多招结果
你想
然后去寻找的结果
先不产生这种
先寻找的结果
然后找到那么两个结果
简单一种就可以了
不用太好
只要拼你现在好一点
就可以了
简单一点
然后你上手融入就可以了
我们这个习惯是一点点两种
只要拼你现在的好一点
简单一点好
固定好两个结果
那里面就像经过小说
这个
就像那个PP的模板
找到那么两个
拼进模板
你不需要10个模板
两个板足够了
有的这个模板
就能保证
你那个PPD做出来就漂亮
啊
第二个问题的话呢
第二个的话呢
有的那个
怎么说
有的PPD之后
你的结果之后
样时之后
你就不需要关注
怎么说了
样的部分
你只需要关注
那种就好了
所以你看
这不就结上很多时间
那你想我来说的话
那每天
看那种的话
我就会关注一个点
我能不能用一句话
把它说清楚
就看了一大段
能不能用一句话
说我自己说的
其实你知道这个
于句话有的时候
很重要啊
你没有说有
有些时候
真的就一句话
你都不需要解构
都不需要什么
比较我的
爱形式都不需要什么
就一句话
比如说我来朋友说
就放一句话
这句话是特别好
就会严歉什么的功能
就会给你变赞
这就是于句话的所有
所以你把动作内容
就看那个东西的深度上去
不断的反复的教演
然后的话呢
你只是有一些灵感
对吧
看数也好啊
思考也好啊
做数也好啊
灵感就随时候进入下来
然后以后
后面在看的时候
不断的就有话
再反过来
你不断有话
我一般会把它翻唱一个解构
什么解构
比如说于句话
说明没有什么意思
然后是是什么
为什么怎么做
可以了
就这么点
对吧
就是按这个结果说
它是什么
一句话
然后是为什么
然后怎么做
好了
就这么一个东西
把他表达开
我一般把你要支持卡片
所以呢
一天我其实如果
我做地铁的时候
想一下
断错所的时候
对吧
想过如果就一个
就可能会有这么惨碎
很小玩笑的
我就很多很多的就小碎片
但是我只关注的
那种其他不溫柔
对吧
然后第三个部分的话
你会发现
一作有意思的
比如说像拍的时候
你像我像拍的时候
没那么复杂
对吧
就是拿着一个指示卡片
一小段
拿上一个结果
一组合
你用多了以后
包括这个结果
你都是现场
你不需要每次我逃
内容也是你的
你之前也想过
所以你像我
我就拿来就拍
因为内容的现场的结果
是现场的
五分钟十分钟
就拍掉视频
所以他是
但是他是非常高餐的
各位
能体会吗
就是拍一段视频的时候
要学会啊
就是把说什么
和怎么说
很开
然后怎么说
这个事实的话
你会影响工程
找到一些结果
不要太多
有那么一点个结果
养成习惯
以后再加做好了以后再加
一两个结果养成习惯
然后你每天就把这个
把观众点放在内容上
然后就不断打茫的内容
然后等你学会拍的时候
在这个内容
按这个结婚
说就快点